ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME TO
THE ASSEMBLY LABOR EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE.
LET US BEGIN THAT WILL START BY
ESTABLISHING THE ROLE.
WILL PROCEED AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
OF THE CHAIR RECOGNIZES THAT IF
SOMEONE EVER SOLACE IS PREPARED
PRESENT ON AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT ARE HERE I REALIZE THAT
WE'RE BEGINNING AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND I APPRECIATE
THE. OPPORTUNITY TO GO I'D
PRESENT AND.
SHE'LL TAKE A VOTE WATSA QUORUM
IS ESTABLISHED MY PRE SHEET THAT
WAS CHAIRMAN I'M HERE TO PRESENT
TO YOU ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY NINE WHICH WOULD
BASICALLY. A TELL CAL OSHA TO
DEVELOP STANDARDS AROUND VALLEY
FEVER IN VALLEY FEVER CASES AND
WHAT WILL. I IN MY MIND IT'S NO
DIFFERENT THAT WHAT WE DO AROUND
HERE REGULATIONS AND WHAT WE DO
FOR.
.
FOR ALL THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE AFFECTED THAT WAY CURRENTLY
CAL OSHA REGULATIONS REGARDING
WORKER HEALTH AND SAFETY AT THE
WORK SITE NOT SPECIFIC TO VALLEY
FEVER PROTECTION EXPOSURE. I
EMPLOYEES THAT WORK OUTDOORS
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO WORK IN
OR AROUND SAWYER ARE ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE TO CONTRACTING VALLEY
FEVER BECAUSE THEY FACE THE
GREATEST.
RIGHT OF DUST EXPOSURE.
I AM TWENTY SIXTEEN YOU MIGHT BE
FAMILIAR.
UP MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
THAT CALTRANS WAS ACTUALLY HIT
WITH A LAWSUIT TWELVE BILLION
DOLLAR LAWSUIT FOR WORKERS AT.
CONTRACTED VALLEY FEVER MORE
RECENTLY THERE WERE A BUNCH OF
EMPLOYEES OUT OF MONTEREY COUNTY
THAT CONTRACTED VALLEY FEVER
WHEN WORKING ON A SOLAR
INSTALLATION SITE. WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS WE WANT CAL OSHA JUST
COME UP WITH SOME STANDARDS AND
SOME GUY GUIDELINES ESPECIALLY
IN THESE? ENDEMIC AREAS THAT
VALLEY FEVER IS PREVALENT AND
TRY TO KEEP SOME MORE WORKERS
SAFE.
THANK YOU OF YOU HAVE BEEN HERE
FOR THE FIRST WITNESS
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS.
MIKE BONTA GONNA BE HALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PATRIOTS
COUNCIL.
AND THE WESTERN STATES COUNCIL
OF SHEET METAL WORKERS WERE IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
BY A.
JUST SALAS IT'S A DEBILITATING
DISEASE THAT HAS A. HUGE IMPACT
ON ANYBODY WHO COMES INTO
CONTACT WITH IT IN OUR COURSE
OUR MEMBERS TO A LOT OF WORK.
OUTSIDE CALLED CONSTRUCTION AND
DISS A GOOD FIRST STEP THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MAKE YOU DO HAVE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES.
DON'T KNOW IF THEY WERE ABLE TO
MAKE IT ENLISTED IN THE ANALYSIS
I APPRECIATE THAT VERY GOOD
OTHERWISE ANYONE ELSE WISHING
AND ON IN SUPPORT.
NICHOLAS CHáVEZ ON BEHALF
UNITED FARM WORKERS AND SUPPORT
THINK LOCAL.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING AT ON IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
I WILL TURN IT TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS.
I THOUGHT MY EYES Y. THANK YOU
THINK MISS CHARLOTTE THANK YOU.
PAJAMAS ALSO BRING THIS FLORIDA
IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
IT WE ADOPTED ON. AND AFTER
SHAPE THAT.
THANK YOU SO REMEMBER.
WE WILL.
WAIT TILL WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM
TO TAKE ACTION ON VOTE.
WE NEED ONE OR TWO MORE.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THINK ANYBODY MEMBERS AND ANY
CLOSING THAT YOU WANNA PROVIDE
SIR AND I APPRECIATE EACH OF YOU
TAKING THE TIME AND ALLOWING ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
TO EDUCATE EVERYONE ON WHAT
VALLEY FEVER IS HOW MANY
FAMILIES IS AFFECTED UP AND DOWN
THE ENTIRE STATE I BELIEVE I
GAVE EACH OF YOU THE YOUR
SPECIFIC COUNTY NUMBERS ABOUT
HOW MANY CASES OF ACTUALLY.
BEEN COUNTED IN YOUR IN YOUR
COUNTIES BUT WITH THAT SAID WE
ALSO KNOW THAT CDC ESTIMATES A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND CASES GO
UNREPORTED EVERY YEAR. SIXTY
PERCENT OF THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
VALLEY FEVER DON'T EVEN KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE IT SO ANYTHING WE
CAN DO TO HELP. THOSE FAMILIES
AND THOSE THAT ARE AFFECTED
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT AND
APPRECIATE.
YOUR RECOMMENDATION.
FOR DISPOSABLES FOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CELIS AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED EFFICACY
I KNOW THAT YOU'VE WORKED ON
THESE ISSUES AT LEAST THE LAST
THREE OR FOUR YEARS AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
IT.
OF THE BILL DOES HAVE.
AYE RECOMMENDATION FROM THIS
CHAIR. AND.
WE WILL BE ASKING THE SERGEANTS
TO CONTINUE CALLING THE MEMBERS
THAT ARE ABSENT SO THAT WE CAN
DISPENSE WITH THIS MATTER RIGHT
AWAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
CHAIR RECOGNIZES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIMOS PRESIDENT WE WELCOME YOU
SOME A MEMBER LIMON PRESENT A.
B. NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX.
THINK YOU CHAIR LOOKING YOU
MEMBERS THAT.
MANY OF YOU HAVE HEARD OF THE
HEALTH BENEFITS OF BREASTFEEDING
FOR BOTH THE MOTHER AND THE BABY
DESPITE THE MANY ESTABLISHED
BENEFITS THE PERCENTAGES OF
AMERICAN WOMEN. THAT EXCLUSIVELY
BREASTFEED THEIR BABIES FOR THE
FIRST SIX MONTHS REMAINS LOW.
WOMEN WHO WORK OUTSIDE.
THE HOME ARE LESS LIKELY TO
INITIATE BREAST FEEDING TO TEND
TO BREASTFEED OR SHORTER LENGTHS
OF TIMES THAN WOMEN WHO ARE
EMPLOYED OUTSIDE OF THE HOME THE
WOMAN WHO ARE NOT EMPLOYED
OUTSIDE OF THE HOME. WOMEN
FREQUENTLY CITE AND SUPPORTIVE
WORK ENVIRONMENT CLEAN A LACK OF
PRIVACY IN A LACK OF HYGIENIC
SPACES AS A REASON FOR
DISCONTINUING BREASTFEEDING.
WITH MORE AND MORE WOMEN WORKING
OUTSIDE THE HOME THIS PRESENTS A
REAL PUBLIC HEALTH CHALLENGE.
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WOULD
REQUIRE THAT THE SPACE MADE
AVAILABLE FOR WOMEN TO EXPRESS
TO EXPRESS BREAST MILK IN THE
WORKPLACE IS NOT A BATHROOM.
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX IS A
SMALL CHANGE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR WORKING
MOTHERS IN TWO WAYS ONE. ADELINE
ST STATUE WITH FEDERAL LAW
SAFEGUARDING THE SUPPORT AND
PROTECTION AGAINST ANY CHANGES
TO THE ACA SO JUST TO BE CLEAR
THE STATUES ARE ALREADY
FEDERALLY IN PLACE.
IT HELPS TO REDUCE TO IT HELPS
TO REDUCE A SIGNIFICANT BARRIER
THAT PREVENTS WOMEN FROM
CONTINUING TO BREASTFEED UPON
RETURNING TO WORK BY ENSURING
THAT THERE IS A PRIVATE AND
CLEAN SPACE AVAILABLE. TO
EXPRESS BREASTMILK.
TODAY AND I DO HAVE A WITNESS
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE OF THE
BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRTH MITCHELL POCKET WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
WE'RE PROUD TO SPONSOR AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WHICH ADDS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EARLY MON
PREVIOUSLY STATED ENSURES THAT
NURSING MOMS HAVE A SPACE OTHER
THAN ABOUT HIM TO EXPRESS MILK
ONCE THEY RETURN TO WORK.
IN TWENTY TEN THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT AMENDED THE FEDERAL
FAIR LABOR STANDARDS ACT TO ADD
NEW WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS FOR
NURSING MOTHERS. REQUIRING THE
PROVISION OF A LOCATION FOR
EXPRESS BUS BREAST MILK OTHER
THAN A BATHROOM THAT IS NEARLY
EMPLOYEES WORK AREA SHIELDED
FROM VIEW AND FREE FROM THE
INTRUSION OF COWORKERS AND
PUBLIC.
GIVEN THE CURRENT UNCERTAINTY AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL SURROUNDING
THE ACA WE BELIEVE IT IS
CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT WORKING
MOMS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE ACCESS
TO A SANITARY LACTATION SPACE.
SHOULD THE FEDERAL LAW GOVERNING
THIS IMPORTANT PROTECTION EVER
BE AMENDED OR REPEALED.
BY NATURE PUBLIC RESTROOMS ARE
UNHYGIENIC LOCATIONS IN WHICH TO
PREPARE FOOD FOR AN INFANT.
THERE IS EVIDENCE TO SHOW THAT
MULTIPLE TYPES OF BACTERIA
PRESENT ON ALL SURFACES
INCLUDING THINGS AND COUNTER
TOPS.
I THINK THAT MOST FOLKS WOULD
NOT WILLINGLY CHOOSE TO PREPARE
MEAL IN THE BATHROOM.
AND WE BELIEVE THE SAME STANDARD
SHOULD APPLY.
TO NURSING MOMS.
WITH THAT THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
WE CALL FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES
AT ON IN SUPPORT BUT IN THE
MEANTIME WE'RE GONNA QUICKLY
ESTABLISHED A ROLL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THURMAN HERE.
FLORA.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
JONES SAWYER PRESIDENT KALRA.
MCCARTY MELENDEZ.
A QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED THANK
YOU.
BUT THOSE WITH AN ADD ON
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
DEREK CLINICS ON BEHALF OF SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT ARE PROBABLY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MY INGRAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RIGHT SPENCER WITH THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OBSTETRICIANS AND
GYNECOLOGISTS DISTRICT NINE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I AT THIS TIME ANY OPPOSITION
.
IT I DIDN'T KNOW MARK CURTIS
WITH CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE ARE HERE I'M JUST ON
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON AB NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX.
THIS BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM
ESTABLISHES A NEW MANDATE
REGARDING LACTATION
ACCOMMODATIONS WELL BY WHEREBY
AN EMPLOYER MUST MAKE A
REASONABLE EFFORT TO PROVIDE A
LOCATION OTHER THAN A BATHROOM
FOR EMPLOYEES TO EXPRESS NOT.
AND THIS MIGHT CREATE AN UNDUE
HARDSHIP FOR EMPLOYERS THAT
SIMPLY DON'T HAVE THE ADDITIONAL
SPACE FOR LOCATION OTHER THAN A
BATHROOM. OUR MEMBER SUPPORT NEW
MOTHERS AND THEIR TRANSITION
BACK TO WORK WE WANT TO MAKE
THIS TRANSITION AS EASY IN PA AS
POSSIBLE BUT FOR SOME EMPLOYERS
THIS WOULD SIMPLY.
CREATE A SIGNIFICANT DIFFICULTY
AND EXPENSE
FOR EXAMPLE A STANDALONE DRIVE
THROUGH COFFEE SHOP SIMPLY MIGHT
NOT HAVE ANOTHER LOCATION FOR AN
EMPLOYEE OTHER THAN A BATHROOM
THAT PROVIDES THERE AND REQUIRED
PRIVACY FOR THIS TYPE ACTED.
THE OTHER STATES THAT THE BILL
WILL CODIFY FEDERAL LAW THE
FEDERAL LAW ACTUALLY INCLUDES
AND HARDSHIP EXEMPTION FOR
LACTATION ACCOMMODATION
ADDITIONALLY AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX ALSO DOES NOT PROVIDE. A
DEFINITION FOR BATHROOM AND THIS
MIGHT UNINTENTIONALLY EXCLUDED
PLACES SUCH AS A WOMAN'S LOUNGE
THAT'S ATTACHED TO A BATHROOM
HAS COUCHES AND CHAIRS AND OTHER
PLACES FOR A PERSON TO EXPRESS
MILK. IN A LOCATION THAT'S
CONSIDERED REASONABLE WITHOUT A
CLEAR DEFINITION OF A BATHROOM
THE SPACES COULD BE REARDED AS
UNACCEPTABLE AND THE COMBINATION
PLACING A FURTHER BURDEN ON AN
EMPLOYER FOR TO MAKE THIS KIND
OF ACCOMMODATION.
WITH CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS SUCH
AS PROVIDING A DEFINITION FOR
BATHROOM AND ALLOWING FOR A
HARDSHIP EXEMPTION FOR EMPLOYERS
THAT SIMPLY DON'T HAVE THE
ADDITIONAL SPACE FOR THIS TYPE
OF ACCOMMODATION. WE WOULD AND.
WE WOULD UNDERSTAND AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX COULD THEN ACHIEVE
ITS GOAL PROVIDING SUITABLE
ACCOMMODATION FOR EMPLOYEES TO
EXPRESS IN THAT PRESS MONTH
WITHOUT OVER BURDENING AND
PLAYERS WITH AN UNREASONABLE
MANDATE. WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND HER STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US ON POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO COLLABORATE ON THE
AMENDMENTS.
THANKS SO MUCH.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
TRACY SALOMON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES ALSO POSING WITH
AMENDED FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED THANK YOU.
KATIE HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WHERE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED FOR THE
REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED THANK
YOU.
BRITNEY SAID SERVICEABLE JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION ALSO POSE MUST
AMENDED FOR THE REASON.
REASONS STATED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
UP TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SIMILAR CALLER THANK YOU I'M. A
THANK YOU SHARON THANK YOU
MEMBER LIMON FOR BRINGING THIS A
BILL FOR AND I BELIEVE THAT.
CODE ALREADY ALLOWS FOR REGIONAL
COMMENDATIONS FOR A FOR
EMPLOYERS.
AND SO I I CERTAINLY RESPECT THE
CONCERNS BUT I THINK THAT.
THAT WAY IT CAN BE MANAGED
THROUGH CURRENT.
THE CURRENT CODE UP IN ADDITION
I REALLY APPRECIATE BRING THIS
FORWARD IS NOT SOMETHING
CERTAINLY THAT MEN ALWAYS THINK
ABOUT BUT. HE CAME TO MY
ATTENTION WHEN I WAS A CITY
HALL.
INTO A NEW CITY HALL SOUNDS A
COUPLE SILICON VALLEY WE JUST
HIT REFRESH OF A MEETING AND
SOMEONE ASKED ME WHERE THE
NURSING ROOM WAS AND I WAS
EMBARRASSED LED THE STATE WE
DON'T HAVE ONE. I'VE HAD TO
CLOSE THE BLINDS AND CLOSE MY
DOOR LAWLER USE MY BUT I OFFICE
BUT SOME IS GOING TO THAT.
I PUT FORWARD LIPS CITY
LEGISLATION TO REQUIRE IT.
NOT ONLY SI HARB OTHER SLEEP
CITIES LIKE CHILDREN'S COUNTY
MUSEUM HAPPY HOLLOW PARK ZOO
WILL BE DIDN'T. I HAVE IT AND
AND SO WE CAN BE RENT FOR A
BATON SO I LEARNED AFTER THAT
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS.
UP AND IT REALLY BECAME PART OF
MY THOUGHT PROCESS AND SO I'M
VERY GRATEFUL THAT THAT YOU
BRING THIS FLORIDA ENSURING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE IS ALSO THINKING
ABOUT. A ABOUT WOMEN QUICKLY
THOSE ARE NOT ONLY THAT ARE
GOING TO PLACES LIKE THE THE AS
AS VISITORS AND GASSED THOSE
RETURNING TO THE WORKPLACE.
TO GIVE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PUMP AS WELL.
SO I'M I LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION.
TO PASS A BILL.
A MOTION A SECOND IT OF SOME
ANOTHER JONES SAWYER. BOMB.
BUT AS SOMEONE WHO IS DIRECTOR
REALISTIC ISSUE LOS ANGELES WHO
WAS INSTRUCTED TO GREAT BUT
WHITE.
WAS UNNECESSARY BECAUSE NO ONE
COMES INTO THE.
THE FIRE STATIONS I SAID ONE DAY
THERE WILL BE HALF OR YOU WILL
BE WOMEN.
AND THEY WE WILL NEED LACTATION
STATIONS AND WHAT I LEARNED IS
ONCE I SAID THAT ONCE I PUT THAT
IDEA THAT. YOU DO NEED IT.
ARM AND WHY YOU NEED IT AND IT
IS A POSSIBILITY THAT.
SOMEONE WILL ACTUALLY USE IT IT
BECAME VERY EASY FROM THEN ON
AND THIS IS MORE FOR. FORUM
RESTAURANT OWNERS AND PEOPLE AND
CAL CHAMBER WANT YOU EX EMBRACE
IT ACCEPTED. ON SAME WOULD WITH
A HANDICAP ACCESS TO THE TIMER.
INDIVIDUAL BUSINESS SAID WE
CAN'T DO HANDICAP ACCESS COULD
CAN'T AFFORD IT WE CAN'T DO IT
ON BUT WE FOUND WAYS TO WHAT YOU
EMBRACE THE IDEA. OF.
ACCOMMODATION SPECTACLE OFTEN
GREAT IDEAS WILL COME FORTH AND
SO I HOPE THAT YOU WORK WITH
THEM.
DE THE OPPOSITION TO TO HELP
SEE WHERE THIS CAN ACTUALLY
HAPPEN.
THINK BACK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
INSULTS FLETCHER I WANT THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I
HAD A WOMEN'S ADVISORY COUNCIL
MEETING AND THE DISTRICT AND
I'M.
WE THOUGHT WE'D BE TALKING ABOUT
PAY INEQUITIES OR. ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE
THEY ALL BROUGHT UP WAS AND
BREASTFEEDING WHEN YOU GO BACK
TO WORK
SO I THINK THAT SOMETIMES IT'S
BEEN AWHILE FOR ME M.. AND SO I.
AT LIKE TO.
REMEMBER THOSE DAYS BUT I AM I A
NEW MOMS IN PARTICULAR I THINK
I'M FACE IT SO DRAMATICALLY THAT
I I REALLY APPRECIATE THIS
LEGISLATION. I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT.
THE OPPOSITION'S STATEMENT ONE
THING I WANT TO POINT OUT FOR
THE FUTURE THE PEOPLE DON'T
THINK IT'S OKAY. I'M TO SIMPLY
HAVE A LOUNGE IN A BATHROOM
BECAUSE AND I WAS ACTUALLY A
STUDENT AT UCLA LAW SCHOOL WHEN
I HAD MY DAUGHTER.
AND THAT IS THE ACCOMMODATIONS I
WAS GIVEN.
IN THE LOUNGES IN THE BATHROOM
LOOKED A LOT LIKE OUR WOMEN'S
BATHROOMS HERE WHICH IS.
A DIRTY COUCH
IN THE SAME ROOM AS A BATHROOM
UP AND SO I I THINK I.
THAT'S NICE BUT LIKE IF YOU
WOULDN'T EAT A SANDWICH
SOMEWHERE THAT YOU PROBABLY
SHOULDN'T. BE FORCED TO
BREASTFEED YOUR CHILD A PUMP
SOMEWHERE.
SO THAT I WON ENCOURAGE YOU TO
HOLD FAST ON YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
AT SAY NINE I I WOULD ALSO JUST
WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AT
YOU KNOW IT'S HARD. TO HEAR OF
THE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY OPPOSITION AND IT
JUST FELT LIKE THERE WAS. NO
RECOGNITION OF THE SANITARY
COUNTY CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN A
RACE AND THAT.
YOU KNOW THE STATE OF MOST
BATHROOMS A WE SEE ANYMORE I
DON'T EVEN THINK PEOPLE WANT TO
USE THE BATHROOMS LET ALONE
EATING IT LITTLE NURSE THEIR
CHILD AND SO THANK YOU FOR.
BEING FORWARD ON THIS AND THAT
IT DOES HAVE THAT YEARS AYE
RECOMMENDATION.
IF YOU LIKE CLUBS WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I FOR THE COMMENTS
AND FEEDBACK THANK YOU TO
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND ALL THE SUPPORTERS A THINK
THAT. THIS IS AN ISSUE AND THAT
DOESN'T JUST IMPACT WOMEN IF WE
CARE ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH IF WE
CARE ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT OUR
YOUTH THAT THE CHILDREN GROW UP
IN A HEALTHY WAY. THIS MATTERS
TO ALL OF US SO WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU LEGAL ROLE.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMAN BY
THURMOND AYE FLORA BY FLORA AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE JONES SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER AYE KALRA KALRA I.
MCCARTY MELENDEZ.
BUT BILLS OUT UNANIMOUSLY THANK
YOU.
TEACHERS ECONOMIC MAKE A MOTION
ABOVE THE BILL SEVENTY NINE THE
SAUCE BILL.
BUT THE NUMBER. NUMBER.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY NINE.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY NINE WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SOME OF OUR CALLERS
ARE SECOND.
WE HAVE MOTION A SECOND PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
ON AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY NINE
SOLACE.
THURMAN AYE THURMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA.
I.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY MELINDA'S.
NOW THAT BILLS OUT.
OUR FINAL BILL THE DAY AB
NINETEEN THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA WE ARE READY WHEN
YOU ARE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURRS.
AB NINETEEN THIRTEEN TO PROVIDE
A TECHNO BANKS TO SENATOR
STEINBERG'S SB FOUR SEVENTY
SEVEN FROM TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN.
WHICH REQUIRES FOREIGN LABOR
CONTRACTORS TO REGISTER
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
COMMISSIONER.
SPECIFICALLY THAT WOULD ENSURE
THE PROPER IMPLEMENTATION OF SP
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN BY REQUIRING
THAT ALL FOREIGN LABOR
CONTRACTORS S ORIGINALLY
INTENDED. ARE REQUIRED TO
REGISTER WITH THE COMMISSIONER
NOT JUST THOSE FOREIGN LABOR
CONTRACTORS RECRUIT WORKERS TO
THE AGE TO BE BE SUBCATEGORY.
AS ESTABLISHED BY S. BEFORE
SEVENTY SEVEN CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES FOREIGN LABOR
CONTRACTORS TO REGISTER WITH THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER.
REQUIRES EMPLOYERS TO HIRE
REGISTERED A POLICIES AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY PROVIDES PROTECTIONS
AND REMEDIES FOR THOSE FOREIGN
WORKERS SOLICITED AND RECRUITED
TO WORK TEMPORARILY IN
CALIFORNIA TO PROTECT THEM FROM
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. AND OTHER
LABOR CODE VIOLATIONS.
LABOR AND SEX TRAFFICKING
CONTINUES TO BE A PERVASIVE
ISSUE IN THE SOLICITATION AND
HIRING. A FOREIGN WORKERS UNDER
ALL BE SIR CATEGORIES.
THE OUR SPONSORS OF WORK WITH
MANY SUCH INS INDIVIDUALS.
GUSTAVO TEMPLE YEAH ALTERADO WAS
RECRUITED IN TWO THOUSAND TEN.
TO TWO THOUSAND TWELVE A MATURE
CON MEDICAL TO WORK IN
CALIFORNIA ON AN H. TWO A. B.
SET PICKING STRAWBERRIES.
HE AND THE OTHER FOUR HUNDRED
WORKERS WERE PART OF THE CASE
WERE CHARGED.
MORE THAN FOURTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN KICKBACKS RECRUITMENT
COSTS PLUS ADDITIONAL COSTS FOR
TRAVEL.
HE AND HIS CO WORKERS WERE
THREATENED WITH BLACKLISTING AND
INTIMIDATED BY EMPLOYERS AFTER
THEY COMPLAINED ABOUT THESE
ABUSES.
THIS TIME THE RETALIATION NEEDS
TO BE CURBED WITH PROTECTIONS
LAID OUT IN S. B. FOUR SEVENTY
SEVEN.
IN LIMITING THE SCOPE OF S.
BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN TO APPLE'S
HE'S RECRUITING UNDER THE AGE TO
BE BE SIR. THE VAST MAJORITY A
TEMPORARY FOREIGN WORKERS COMING
TO CALIFORNIA REMAIN UNPROTECTED
AND SUBJECT TO THE DOCUMENTED
ABUSES OF UNSCRUPULOUS AT
POLICIES.
INSTEAD OF PROTECTING OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND TEMPORARY
WORKERS COMING TO CALIFORNIA AS
INTENDED.
PROTECTIONS ARE ONLY AVAILABLE
TO ABOUT THREE THOUSAND
TEMPORARY AGE TO BE WORKERS.
AB NINETEEN THIRTEEN FULFILL THE
INTENT OF SP FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN.
BY MAKING CLEAR THAT ALL FAIR
FOREIGN LABOR CONTRACTORS ARE
COVERED.
WITH ONLY TWO EXCEPTIONS
J. ONE VISAS AND TALENT AGENCY
RECRUITERS.
AS A RESULT.
THE BILL WOULD ALIVE A LOT TO
COMPORT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
INTENT AT POLICIES RECRUITING
WORKERS UNDER ALL BE SICK
CATEGORIES WITH TO LIMITED
EXCEPTIONS ARE COVERED.
BUT COVERING ALL FOREIGN LABOR
CONTRACTORS AB NINETEEN THIRTEEN
WILL ENSURE THAT ALL FOREIGN
WORKERS ARE PROTECTED AGAINST
WAGE THEFT HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
OTHER WORKER ABUSES.
WITH ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY TESTIMONY ARE MELANIE
QUIBUS REPRESENTING THE
COALITION AGAINST SLAVERY AND
TRAFFICKING. AS WELL AS DAVID
JONES WITH MAYOR DARRELL
STEINBERG STAFF.
WHAT THE FIRST WITNESS?
THAT AFTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AS MELANIE CUEVAS
ON THE PRO BONO LOBBYIST FOR CAP
THE COALITION TO ABOLISH SLAVERY
AND TRAFFICKING.
THE BILL'S SPONSOR AS WELL AS
THE NATION'S LARGEST PROVIDER OF
COMPREHENSIVE SERVICES FOR
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN
THE UNITED STATES.
ARE LEGISLATIVE WORK COMES MY
BOOTS ON THE GROUND EXPERIENCE
SO I SUCH I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
WITH YOU ONE DOCUMENTED ABUSE
SEVEN EACH TO AB SO SITUATION.
A FEW YEARS AGO MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THAI WORKERS WERE
RECRUITED TO COME TO THE UNITED
STATES FOR AGRICULTURE
EMPLOYMENT SOME OF THEM HEAD
UPWARDS OF TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. AND AS A RECRUITMENT
THE. WHEN THEY GOT TO UNITED
STATES THERE HEAVILY INDEBTED.
THEIR RECRUITERS CONFISCATED
PASSPORTS.
FORCE WORKERS TO LIVE IN RHODE
VESTED QUARTERS THE WORK THAT
RANCID FOOD AND THE RECORDERS
MADERA RECRUITERS THREATENED
DEPORTATION IF THE WORKERS
COMPLAINED.
IT'S CLEAR TO US THAT DESPITE
THE CURRENT EXISTING REGULATION
OF FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS IN
CALIFORNIA.
FURTHER PROTECTIONS ARE NEEDED
WHEN A FOREIGN LEADERS ARE
CONTRACTED UNDER EACH TO A V.
SAYS. AND FACTOR REPORT BY THE
CLERK PELORUS PROJECTS STATE
THAT I WORK WITH THE
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY IS STILL
THE NUMBER ONE INDUSTRY.
ASSOCIATED WITH THE VICTIMS
REPORTING LABOR TRAFFICKING
ABUSE.
I WHILE MANY FOREIGN LABOR
CONTRACTORS DO OUT ACT ETHICALLY
SOME ARE DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN
LABOR TRAFFICKING. AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS JUST LIKE EVERY OTHER
WORK ON ITS HAVE PREVIOUS THAT
NEEDS THE PROTECTIONS AFFORDED
AN SP FOUR SEVEN SEVEN AND IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THIRTEEN. BOTH
WORKERS AND CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES ALIKE WILL BENEFIT
FROM ONE CLEAR AND COMPREHENSIVE
FOREIGN LABOR CONTRACTOR POLICY.
I THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER STATED IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN BECAUSE
SPONSORED SP FIVE.
SIXTEEN WITH SENATOR STEINBERG
AND EXIT SUCCESSOR AS BEFORE
SEVEN SEVEN WHICH I TRUST THAT
GOVERNOR'S FUNDING CONCERNED AND
ULTIMATELY WAS SIGNED INTO LAW.
HOWEVER WHEN YOU'RE WORKING WITH
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER ON
IMPLEMENTING THIS.
WE REALIZED THAT WE HAD MADE A
TERRIBLE MISTAKE AND WHILE WE
BELIEVE THAT THE LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL AND CLARIFIES THAT ALL
THESE THE CATEGORIES EXCEPT FOR
JAY ONE AND REGISTER TOWN
AGENCIES. ARE COVERED BY THE
BILL WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
ERRONEOUS PLACEMENT IN STATUTE
DOES CREATE SOME CONFUSION AND
WE ARE IN FRONT OF THE LABOR
COMMITTEE TODAY. AND TO ENSURE
THAT THE NECESSARY TECHNICAL
FIXES MADE TO CLARIFY THE BILL'S
FULL LEGISLATIVE INTENT FROM
TWENTY THIRTEEN AND TWENTY
FOURTEEN. WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
LEGISLATION IS PASSED IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AS ONE OF THE ONLY A
LOT THAT CAN HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON REDUCING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN CALIFORNIA. CAST
ONCE AGAIN ASKS FOR THE SUPPORT
OF THE LABOR COMMITTEE ON THIS
MEASURE THINK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
YES MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR MAKE SLIGHT
CORRECTION OR NOT UNTIL STAFF ON
THE LOBBYIST FOR THE CITY'S
ECONOMIC YOU ON BEHALF OF I'M
HALF BAKED REAL STANDARD. A WE
ARE HERE ADMITTED EVERYBODY
WORKS FOR DEL STALAG.
SO YOU WOULD AGREE WITH THE
AUTHOR THINK THE AUTHOR THIS
DOES CLARIFY THE INTENT OF THE
OF THE AUTHOR TO OF.
I EXTENDED PROTECTIONS TO ALL
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND WORKERS
THAT ARE.
COME HERE FOR UNDERFUNDED
FOREIGN PROGRAMS UP
UNFORTUNATELY SACRAMENTO DOES
HAVE ANOTHER DISTINCTION IS WE
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM HERE
ABOUT.
SO IN AS MUCH AS THIS BILL WILL
HELP CLOSE THAT GAP AND IN THAT
LOOPHOLE.
WE'VE WE WOULD ASK THAT YOU A
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND PASS IT ON
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
NICHOLAS THOMAS ON BEHALF THE
UNITED FARM WORKERS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
ADD ON IN SUPPORT.
SCENE DOT IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TODAY.
FOR THE OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
HE'S COME TO THE TABLE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE I MATTHEW ON
WITH WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION
AND WE ARE RESPECTIVELY OPPOSED
TO AB NINETEEN THIRTEEN.
IT'S HEARTBREAKING FRANKLY CARE
ABOUT CASES WHERE THERE'S BEEN
OF ABUSE OF WORKERS ON ANY CASES
THAT WERE A HEARING ABOUT THIS
AFTERNOON. ARE FRANKLY ART
AGAINST FEDERAL LAW ON THEIR
TREATMENT FEES.
BEING PROMISED A JOB THAT YOU
ARE NOT RECEIVING AND THAT
RECEIVING.
THE WAGES AND HOURS IN A
WRITTEN FORM. ALSO WANTED JUST
OUTLAYS SOME OF THAT.
ON THE AT THE OUTSET.
WE THERE IS A PROGRAM FOR THE
TRADE WAS NOT OVERLOOKED DURING
THE NEGOTIATIONS FOR AS BEFORE
SEVENTY SEVEN IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
WHICH CREATED THE FOREIGN LABOR
CONTRACTING LICENSING PROGRAM.
IT WAS SIMPLY NOT INTENDED TO
BE COVERED BECAUSE THE LACK OF
NECESSITY DO SO BUT BECAUSE
TARTIKOFF OR BY A MORE
RESTRICTIVE H. TWO WAY PROGRAM
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
AND CALIFORNIA'S FARM LABOR
CONTRACTING LICENSING SYSTEM
WHICH THE FOREIGN LABOR
CONTRACTING SYSTEM WAS ACT
LARGELY BASED ON THE AS A MODEL.
ANNETTE MODELS ACTUALLY CALLED
OUT IN THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
JUDICIARY ANALYSIS.
TRADING SP FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN.
THERE'S A PROGRAM IS IS
REGULATED BY RESTRICTIVE FEDERAL
PROGRAM THERE ARE SEVERAL
PLANETS THAT I'D LIKE TO OUTLINE
THEIR EACH WAY WORKERS RISK MUST
RECEIVE ACCURATE WRITTEN
INFORMATION ABOUT THE WAGES
HOURS WORKING CONDITIONS AND
BENEFITS OF THE EMPLOYMENT BEING
OFFERED.
THIS INFORMATION ABOUT THE
SPIRIT YOU PRIOR TO GETTING A
VISA. AND NO LATER THAN ON THE
FIRST DAY OF WORK.
TO RECEIVE THIS INFORMATION
LANGUAGE UNDERSTOOD BY THE
WORKER WE THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT.
ARE ALSO CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IS
THAT WORKERS HAVE A RIGHT TO BE
FREE FROM DISCRIMINATION OR
DISCHARGE FOR FILING A COMPLAINT
TESTIFYING OR EXCITING A RIGHTS
IT ANYWAY OR HELPING OTHERS TO
DO SO.
AND EMPLOYERS MUST COMPLY WITH
ALL OTHER APPLICABLES LAWS
INCLUDING THE PROHIBITION
AGAINST HOLDING WORKERS
PASSPORTS OR OTHER IMMIGRATION
DOCUMENTS.
ARE IN ADDITION WERE SUBJECT TO
CALIFORNIA'S FARM LABOR
CONTRACTING LICENSING SYSTEM.
AND AS A REGARD HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WHICH IS ALSO.
IN IMPORTANT.
AREA THAT NEEDS TO ALWAYS BE
SAFEGUARDED.
FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS ARE ONE
OF TEN OR ELEVEN SPECIFIC
OCCUPATIONS THAT MUST POST A
WORKPLACE POSTER. OF REGARDING
HUMAN TRAFFICKING INFORMATION
FOR WORKERS AND THAT INFORMATION
IS PROVIDED BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE.
AND WHERE WE REMAIN RESPECTFULLY
POSTED BILL AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
BUT YOU KNOW THE NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON OF BRIGHT LITTLE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION OF RESPECTFULLY POSTS
AND WOOD REQUEST YOU KNOW VOTE I
DON'T NEED TO ADD VERY MUCH TO
WHAT MR ALLEN SAID. OTHER THAN
TO NOTE THAT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT REMEMBER THAT AGE TO A
PROGRAM EMPLOYERS ARE ALREADY
REQUIRED OFFER EMPLOYMENT
CONTRACTS TO THEIR EMPLOYEES
THAT ARE REGULATED AND IT FORCED
UNDER FEDERAL LAW. AND IN
FEDERAL COURT.
EACH REPROGRAM USERS HAVE TO
OBTAIN CERTIFICATIONS ARE
REGULATED BY THREE DIFFERENT
FEDERAL AGENCIES.
I THINK IT MIGHT BE FAIR TO SAY
THAT MOST OF WHAT THE US
DEPARTMENT LABOR DOESN'T
CALIFORNIA IS ACTUALLY RELATED
TO H. TO A IN FORSMAN.
AND THEY ARE VERY ACTIVE AND WE
SEE PRETTY REGULAR PRESS
RELEASES UNFORTUNATELY WHEN THEY
FIND.
EMPLOYERS WHO ARE NOT DOING WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO WHILE THE
VAST MAJORITY OF EMPLOYERS WHO
EMPLOY EACH TO WORKERS DO WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO.
ARE AYE OBJECTION TO IT AB
NINETEEN THIRTEEN BOILS DOWN TO
THE FACT THAT WE DON'T THINK
IT'S GOING TO DO VERY MUCH. TO
ENCOURAGE EMPLOYERS WERE NOT
ALREADY INCLINED TO TO OBEY THE
LAW. AND COMPLY WITH FEDERAL AND
STATE LAW AND WILL DO VERY MUCH
TO INDUCE THOSE WHO WERE NOT SO
INCLINED TO BE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE LAW.
SO THAT WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALICE TO HELP YOU
WITH CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
ALSO POSED FOR THE REASONS
STATED THE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON VEHICULAR VALLEY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HAD LABOR ASSOCIATION
AS WELL AS BOARD MEMBER FOR
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL. AND WE
OPPOSE THE BILL FOR THE REASONS
STATED PREVIOUSLY. THANK YOU.
MARTY FISCHER CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
A MICHAEL MILLER THE COMPANY
CESSATION OF WINE GRAPE GROWERS
WERE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE.
THANK YOU.
PETABYTE SHARIA'S ON BEHALF OF
THE FAMILY WINE MAKERS
CALIFORNIA AND OPPOSITION THINK
YOU THINK YOU.
EHRENREICH BERG ON BEHALF OF THE
WE IMPAIR GROWERS GRAIN AND FEED
SEED AND OTHER AG GROUPS AND
OPPOSITION.
BANK YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE WISHING
ADELINE OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE TURNING TO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
SENATE ON SAWYER THE YOU KNOW I
I DO REMEMBER OF VOTED FOR S.
B..
.
FOR SEVEN SEVEN TO GOD FOURTEEN
AND I I DO RECALL THAT THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF THEN PRO TEM.
DEL CYBER WAS TO COVER ALL
FOREIGN LABOR. UP CONTRACTORS
WITH THESE WITH THESE BILLS. AND
AS SOMEONE ELSE BEEN ON
IMPLEMENTING PART AND NOW A
LAWMAKER. OUR NOTICE SOMETIMES
WE.
ELECTED OFFICIALS BUMPASS
LAWS THAT IS NOT ALWAYS.
.
IT'S NOT ALWAYS A. THE WAY THAT
WE WANTED.
AND I ARE A COMMEND MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER KALRA.
FOR PROVIDING THIS
CLARIFICATION CUTTING IS REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO THAT.
I'M DOING SO PROTECT SO.
IN THIS INFORMED WORKERS FROM
BEING CHARGED.
BOB REOCCURRING FEES ASSIGNED
UNFAIR WORK CONDITION OR THE
WHITE COERCED AGAINST THEIR
THEIR LEGAL CONTRACTS AND SO
HOPEFULLY. IN YOUR CLOSING. YOU
CAN ADDRESS SOME OF THE THE
CONCERNS THAT THE OPPOSITION
HAVE FOR THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD.
THE BILL HAS EMOTIONS SECOND AND
A SECOND. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
SAY NOT.
IF YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
SIMON CALLED THE THANK YOU CHAIR
AND THINK IT'S A MEMBER JONES
SAWYER FOR COMMENTS AND I HAVE A
LETTER WAS PROVIDED BY A MERE
STEINBERG IN OCTOBER. OF WHICH
VERY CLEARLY STATES THAT IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN HIS STAFF.
AND HE WERE PART OF NUMEROUS
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE BUSINESS
INTERESTS INTEREST THAT
VIGOROUSLY OPPOSE THE BILL. AS
PART OF THOSE NUMEROUS
CONVERSATIONS AND AS WE KNOW
MAYOR STAMBERG YOU KNOW IT IS AS
ONE THAT'S GONNA. UP BRINGS MANY
PEOPLE TO THE TABLE AS POSSIBLE
OTHER VERY VERY TO THE RETURN
VERY NARROWLY. CRAFTED
EXCEPTIONS
AND THAT WAS FOR OUR TALENT
AGENCIES AND BRIDGE A ONE PIECE
HAS BECAUSE OF OTHER.
MORE STRENUOUS OF REGULATIONS
IN THOSE ARENAS AND SO ARE IT'S
VERY CLEAR.
THAT
THAT WAS IT WAS NOT THE
INTENTION TO EXCLUDE.
OF FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS
OUR AGE TO A WORKERS A AS PART
OF AS BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN THE
PLACEMENT OF THE BILL AND.
WAS PLACED IN THE CODE SECTION
IS WHAT CAUSED THE NARROWING OF
THE BILL TO ABOUT THREE THOUSAND
WORKERS AS OPPOSED TO THE
APPROXIMATE HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND WORKERS. OF THAT THEN
SENATOR STEINBERG HAD INTENDED
THE BILL TO COVER AND AGAIN EVEN
DOES BUSINESS INTERESTS HE WAS A
CONVERSATION AT THE TIME KNEW
THAT AT THE TIME. AND AND THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY REALLY TO
FULFILL THE MISSION OF AS BEFORE
SEVENTY SEVEN IN A WAY THAT WAS
INTENDED SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY BOOK THANK YOU SIR CHAIR.
THANK YOU SIR NOW KALRA FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY TO PROTECT WORKERS FROM
ABUSE.
THIS A BILL DOES HAVE MEANT AYE
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR OF
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THURMOND AYE
THURMOND AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA
AYE KALRA AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE MELENDEZ.
THE BILL ITSELF HE REGULATIONS
THANK YOU.
OF THESE ARE ALL THE BILL'S WE
HAVE. WE HAVE SOME MEMBERS
WISHING ACT AT ALL.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY NINE
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I.
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE.
THAT'LL PLEASE SIR.
NO NO SIR WE HAVE COMPLETED OUR
BUSINESSES HEARING IS ADJOURNED
THANK YOU.
WHILE.
RIGHT FOR THE LAST.
I HAD NO IDEA THAT BUDGET SUB
WAS.
CAN BE MEETING.
THANK YOU